I certainly do believe in world peace
even though we have seen as you say all
these wars and to outlaw century we had
World War one and World War two and some
would alway also say that we had a third
world war and during this century the
world has mobilized more than perhaps
ever before it's material militaristic
forces the world is presently spending
1.7 trillion dollars a year for military
whilst according to un figures only some
ten percent of these resources would be
enough to meet all the Millennium
Development Goals that governments have
agreed to around the world so whose
priorities are we following but lately
there has been perhaps for the first
time in a long long time a people's
reaction against war there is a
tiredness of war we saw it just recently
in relation to Syria the parliament in
England said no there is search for
diplomatic contacts between the parties
and in a way I think if people knew more
about how we are misusing the world's
resources they would be more eager to
say no to war because how can we keep up
social justice how can we have human
rights for all how can we have good
schools culture health system if we
spend our money on on arms and we have
recently got a arms trade
three T which is wonderful but it needs
to be implemented and we need to go even
further and say we should also have a
treaty against arms production because
as long as there are so many ARMs
floating around there are the risk that
these arms will be used but I believe in
most people one thing to have peace in
their daily life peace in the family
peace in the street peace in the
workplace peace in the closed
environment and peace on the world basis
and when we understand that we cannot
just point at the others as the bad guys
and think that we are the only
exceptions being the good guys when we
stop pointing at each other and instead
start cooperating and use the UN we have
gotten after the Second World War the
the UN which says no more war we will
help children in the world to avoid the
scourges of a war when when we have
enough knowledge I think people will be
more vocal in insisting that we need
peace we want peace and that the war
machinery the military the armies are
there only because we think that the
others are bad if we think that the
others are good and we need to get to
know them and cooperate with them we
will have work this culture of peace